International Women's Day is one week
from today and we will celebrate all
next week a number of influential women
will speak with us including model and
UNICEF ambassador
Halima Adhan senator Kirsten Gillibrand
and retired astronaut Peggy Whitson we
also sent out her correspondence to Asia
Africa and Europe for a special series
to see what motherhood means around the
world as well as in the US
[Music]
I'm Alex Wagner at a KinderCare in New
York daycare centers like this one
except babies as young as six weeks
that's because an absence of paid family
leave many women to find it necessary to
return to work before their babies are
even sleeping through the night coming
up next week we explore why the u.s. is
the only developed nation without a paid
parental leave program and what it means
for moms
I'm never patter in some guru King it's
bathtime in this village here women are
learning to become mothers in the
community where men are bad
I've been Traci in Beijing China where
the toys kids have may look familiar but
the way they're raised may not it's
often a multi-generational affair with
both parents and grandparents sharing
the burden and living together
I'm Holly Williams I'm about to become a
mother for the second time and I have
come to the country that statistics show
could be the best place in the world to
be a mother part of the reason for that
is emergency drills like this one for
that story next week on CBS this morning
[Music]
I can't wait for this our coverage
starts Monday with our story on parental
leave right here in the US